[Music]
let's move on to the mcu characters who
will appear in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness
now that it's clear that won the maxima
of elia scarlet witch will be joining
doctor strange in his second solo film
the cast now also includes tom
hiddleston and his character
loki you should skip the following if
you haven't seen the season finale of
loki yet due to
major spoiler alert in episode 6
arriving at the end of diamond space
loki along with sylvie meets nathaniel
richards aka
kang the scientist from the 3rd
millennium ad is the founder of the time
variants authority
tva for short which was created to
protect the real timeline against
undeserved manipulation not without
reason
since in other timelines kang is known
by his nickname the destroyer rather
than as a responsible scientist
unlike his evil self richard doesn't
want to be a tyrant which is why he
wants to hand over responsibility
regarding the real timeline to
loki and sylvie however sylvie decides
to kill the scientist
and transport loki back to the past
opening up the mcu's gigantic
multiverse in addition to the chaos the
new big mcu villain kang the destroyer
should also make his entrance soon he
will replace thanos and will
even be a bit more powerful than his
predecessor as
kang can easily rule over space and time
for the mcu heroes of the upcoming
movies
this won't be a piece of cake because
due to the open multiverse
you can never tell whether you're facing
the good or the bad kang
in any case we're looking forward to tom
hiddleston's appearance in the upcoming
doctor strange along with a freshly
confirmed second season of loki of
course
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness will be released on march 25th
2022 marvel's long-awaited fourth phase
movie black widow has recently been
released
and has been met with mostly positive
reviews one could almost forget that
this was scarlett johansson's last film
as black widow as the 36 year old is now
leaving the mcu behind
after a decade of success in addition to
her last marvel movie however
another internet phenomenon has been
causing a sensation
as many videos of the scarlett johansson
look alike have been circulating on take
talk for some time
if you didn't know any better you could
swear that scarlett johansson herself or
at least a well done deep fake is
involved here the young woman with a
take dog named kate johansen is
currently astounding many mcu fans
precisely so because she openly uses the
striking resemblance for her videos
in fact some fans are even speculating
that the take talk user could simply
replace scarlett johansson in the event
that marvel takes notice of the
doppelganger
we disagree though after all the
character black widow will be useless
within the mcu in the next few years
and won't play a role anymore after her
solo movie in phase four
so fans will have to say goodbye to
black widow in spite of her look alike
u.s superstar dwayne johnson has often
hinted at the costume of his character
black adam in the past
few days ago he let the cat out of the
back and posted an exclusive picture
from the set on instagram showing him in
the center with his new suit
in the post the 49 year old also
somewhat describes his fancy outfit
saying that it was deliberately not
designed like a typical dc or marvel
suit that is
without any muscle padding in addition
to the small knock on his last train
acting colleagues the strong skin tight
structure and the relatively wide
neckline
also stand out highlighting johnson's
muscles optimally
it would have been interesting to see a
view from the front since that's the
most crucial thing about a superhero
suit
in another post the actor gives us a
hint regarding the making of black adam
as it seems that johnson's muscles as
his suit will be optimized in
post-production
in that case black adam would more
likely resemble a comic book superhero
rather than a cinematic one we're
definitely eager to see the final look
and
can't wait to see new footage on dc's
black adam
the movie will be released on july 29th
2022
the time is near dennis villeneuve's
remake of the classic dune will be
released in movie theaters
via twitter the responsible parties
announced that the new video footage
will hit selected imax theaters next
week on july 21st and 22nd
in addition to the trailer a clip from
the film will also be screened
after all a trip to the cinema should be
well worth it for dune fans
in front of the camera we can look
forward not only to spectacular sand
worm chases and a nasty villain
but above all two appearances by timothy
chalamet rebecca ferguson oscar
isaac josh brolin zendaya jason mamoa
and many other actors recently the film
adaption of the book of the same name by
frank herbert was postponed again and
will now be released in the us on
october 22nd
instead of october 1st are you excited
about the blockbuster
and if so will you go to the cinema next
week to watch the new trailer as soon as
possible
feel free to tell us in the comments
below
almost three years ago use actress hella
bailey auditioned for disney's remake of
the little mermaid and now filming
is officially done fittingly the 21 year
old posted their first image of herself
in her new role on instagram in the
picture description she thanks
everyone involved and expressed her joy
about the project which
in fact started when she was still a
teenager however her commitment has not
only provided cheers in the fan
community
as many were bothered by the major
deviation from the cartoon
original from 1989 ranging from the skin
color to the hair the latter is still a
mystery as she
only ever posted photos with covered
hair during the shoot leading many fans
to speculate that she might have dyed
her hair or even worn a wig
sadly you can't really tell from
bayley's picture but images leaked from
the set weeks ago certainly don't
suggest a red dye job we also cannot
spot aerial striking finn in the
instagram picture a pretty clear sign of
cgi post-production when exactly we'll
get to see the new aerial and the remake
of the same name is still unclear but we
assume a release in the coming year
last year shooting was concluded in
north carolina and now
post-production is also done the talk is
of course
of the now fifth screen movie in line
with the project's completion those
responsible published a picture taken in
the studio where the final touches were
added to the film up until recently
particularly interesting is that the
images also give us a first glimpse of
the new serial killer with a world
famous mask
horror nostalgics and fans of the old
films will be pleased to see that the
killer wears more or less the same mask
as always in the production it is still
unclear what exactly the plot of the new
horror flick will consist of
but at least we know the actors who will
be appearing known returnees are neff
campbell as sydney prescott david
arquette as
dooley riley kourtney cox as gail
weathers and marley shelton as
judy hicks new cast members include
melissa barrera
jenna ortega jack wait mason gooding
dylan minnette
and many others you won't have to wait
too long either since screen 5 will be
released early next year on january 14th
2022
for decades robert jordan's 14 part book
series
the wheel of time has been one of the
best fantasy epics
appropriately enough a series of its own
was then announced in 2017 which is set
to appear on amazon prime later this
year
as a matter of fact this streaming
server seems so impressed by the success
of the book adaption that had recently
commissioned an additional film trilogy
camp cretaceous and thor
author zack stance is said to be
responsible for the screenplay
the first movie is to be titled age of
legends and as the name suggests is to
be said in the era of the legends
although there are various stories about
in the book series the books are set
thousands of years after that the age of
legends is characterized by a kind of
apocalypse that destroyed large parts of
the world the last chance of humanity's
survival is a group of women who gather
at the white tower
and fight against the imminent
destruction of the planet
this synopsis also talks about a
futuristic utopia which raises a few
questions given that the events take
place
thousands of years before the books we
are looking forward to more information
about
age of legends and are eagerly awaiting
the release of the series which is
planned for this year
[Music]
oh